معنا من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي اهلا بك معنا اذا 107 ايام من هذه
الحرب ولم يتحقق هدف تدمير حماس باعتراف
ضباط اسرائيليين وحتى التقارير
استخباراتيه امريكيه تتحدث عن انه الحركه
حركه حماس لا تزال قادره على ضرب اسرائيل
لاشهر في اعتقادك ماذا وراء خروج هذه
التصريحات
الان
نعم تحيه لكم ومشاهدي قناه
الجزيره لا شك بان هذه التصريحات التي
تصدر الان هي تنم عن واقع وعن تجربه
خاضتها القوات الصهيونيه طوال الفتره
الماضيه مع مع فصائل المقاومه وبالتالي
عندما توضع الخطط العسكريه يجب ان توضع
على اسوا سيناريو يمكن ان تواجهه هذه
القوات بما فيها هذه التقديرات التي
يتكلمون عنها اليوم بمعنى بان الخطط
العسكريه التي وضعت منذ البدايه بان
القوات سوف تسيطر على هذه على قطاع غزه
بشكل كامل قبل نهايه العام الماضي فهذا
يعني بان هناك خطا في التقديرات التي قدمت
وهناك خطا في المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
التي بنيت عليها العمليه العسكريه يضاف
الى ذلك بان القتال في المناطق المبنيه لا
يمكن ان يوضع له جدول زمني محدد في مثل
هذه العمليات لان هذه العمليات تعتمد على
الاداء القتالي على الارض وهناك مشاكل
كثيره تواجهها القوات الصهيونيه يعني
عندما يتك كلمون بان التقديرات الصهيونيه
تتكلم على ان الانفاق في غزه لا تتجاوز ال
100 ميل معنى هذا بانها لا تتجاوز ال 160
م بينما الحقيقه تقول والتقديرات
الاستخباراتيه الامريكيه اليوم تقول بانه
شبكه الانفاق تصل الى 450 ميل
بمعنى تصل الى طول اكثر من 725 م في
المدينه وهذا يعني بان هناك خطا كبير جدا
في التقديرات الاستخباراتيه للجيش
الصهيوني بما فيها الخطط العسكريه التي
وضعت يضاف الى هذا بان الاداء القتالي كان
ضعيف جدا لذلك بان هذه هذه التقديرات الان
الذي بدات تظهر تعطي دلاله واضحه على ان
هناك مشكله حقيقيه تواجهها القوات
الصهيونيه في تحقيق الاهداف وهناك مازق
حقيقي تواجهه في مساله الانفاق وكيفيه
القضاء عليها يعني عندما يتكلم قسم من
الخبراء الصهاينه يقولون بان فتحه الانفاق
ما يقارب 5700 فتحه طيب الجيش الصهيوني
يقول لحد هذه اللحظه تم تدمير ما يقال
1100 فتحه من هذه الانفاق بمعنى هناك لا
تزال
4600 فتحه وهذه اشكاليه كبيره جدا خصوصا
وانه منطقه خان يونس ومنطقه رفح والمنطقه
الوسطى لازالت هذه الفصائل يعني لازالت
بقدراتها القتاليه يعني يمكن لها ان تخوض
حرب تستمر اشهر متعدده يضاف الى ذلك اذا
ما تكلمنا بان التقديرات الاستخباراتيه
تقول بان الاسرى في هذه المنطقه فهذا يعني
يجب على القوات الصهيونيه تستخدم القوه
التدميريه وراينا بالامس كيف تم تدمير
مربع كامل في منطقه عبسان الكبيره اذا كان
القضاء على حماس يتطلب
اشهر لانها قادره على المقاومه لشهور كما
جاء في هذه التقييمات المسؤولون
الاسرائيليون على راسهم نتنياهو يقولون ان
القتال سيستمر لاشهر بالتالي هل يعني
الامر ان هذه التقييمات قد تؤثر فعليا على
استراتيجيه الاحب ام انها متواصله للشهور
بسبب هذه القدرات لحماس
نعم دعينا نقول بان
دائما القرار في الحرب هو بداء يبدا بقرار
سياسي وتبدا القطاعات العسكريه تنفذ هذا
القرار ولكن اذا ما جئنا الى القاده
العسكريين سيجدون بان عمليه استمرار
القتال في مدينه غزه ستسبب لهم اشكاليه
كبيره جدا يعني عندما يتكلم قسم من قاده
القاده صهاينه المتقاعدين يقولون بان
الاستمرار في القتال في غزه بمعنى استمرار
الخسائر
تاكل الدعم الدولي يضاف الى هذا بان الضغط
الاقتصادي سيكون كبير جدا يضاف الى هذا
بان هناك جبهه الضفه بدات تضغط الجبهه
الشماليه مع لبنان بدات تضغط اذا هناك
اشكال حقيقي في مساله استمرار هذه الحرب
ولكن يبدو بان القرار باستمرار هذه الحرب
لكي يحافظ نتنياهو وحكومته على على وضعه
الحالي باستمرار في الحكومه القرار القرار
سياسي في استمرار الحرب ولكن على القرارات
العسكريه هو خطا كبير جدا ان تستمر هذه
المعركه التي تستنزف القدرات الصهيونيه
سواء القدرات البشريه او القدرات الماديه
التي تشمل تدمير الاليات وما الى ذلك
والقضيه الاخرى بانه استمرار هذه العمليه
لن يوفر لهم تنفيذ الاهداف التي وضعت من
اجلها الخطه العسكريه الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي كنت معنا من اسطنبول شكرا جزيلا
لك